Almost 50 years after the last mission to
the moon, there are still questions the expeditions
didn’t answer.
Now though thanks to some archival sleuthing,
one of those mysteries has been solved and
it turns out the solution is… kinda dumb.
It all started when the Apollo 15 mission
in 1971 and the Apollo 17 mission in 1972
buried some platinum thermometers in the lunar
surface.
They were planted at different depths, from
a meter to two-and-a-half meters down.
The goal was to see how heat flowed from the
interior of the moon out to the surface, which
would help scientists learn about the moon’s
interior, like if it had a hot core like the
Earth and the rate of internal geologic activity.
But they found something they didn’t expect:
when astronauts visited the moon they may
have altered its temperature -- just by being
there.
Although they didn’t figure that out until
recently.
4.
The thermometers reported a gradual uptick
in temperature by one and a half to three
and a half degrees celsius, and nobody could
pin down exactly why.
A few things could be eliminated right away,
like the sun.
Even though temperatures on the moon swing
wildly over a lunar day, the probes were deep
enough in the lunar soil to avoid the sun’s
effect.
It also couldn’t be the probes’ power
source, as the thermoelectric generators were
far enough away from the thermometers to rule
them out.
But there were still other possibilities,
like fluctuations in the moon’s orbit, radiation
from Earth, or maybe some lasting effect from
the astronauts.
We didn’t know because of a bureaucratic
whoopsie.
The thing is, each of these probes beamed
back temperature data for years.
The data were recorded on 7-track magnetic
tapes, which were then analyzed and archived.
But when the experiment ended in 1977, only
tapes up to 1974 had been analyzed and stored
away.The rest from 1975 to 1977 were lost,
And it wasn’t until 2010 that NASA started
searching for old mission data from Apollo
and other programs, and lordy were there tapes.
Researchers discovered 440 of them had somehow
wound up at the Washington National Records
Center, presumably right next to where they
keep the Arc of the Covenant.
440 tapes sounds like a lot, but it’s less
than 10% of the missing data, and what was
found was badly degraded.
In another stroke of luck they found weekly
logs of the probe’s temperatures during
the missing years at the Lunar and Planetary
Institute in Houston.
So, after eight years of searching and analyzing
they finally had all the pieces of the puzzle.
The new data showed that the probes kept warming
all the way until their demise in 1977, and
the ones closer to the surface warmed first,
meaning the heat was coming from above and
slowly penetrating downward.
That made one scenario the most likely fit:
humans did it.
A quick peek at pictures of the landing sites
taken by a probe currently orbiting the moon
revealed how.
Turns out setting up those experiments on
the moon involved a lot of shuffling about.
That kicked up the bright shiny dust on the
moon’s surface, exposing darker soil beneath.
That darker soil absorbed more sunlight, causing
the thermometers to record higher temperatures.
So after all this time, it was just us.
As soon as we set foot on the moon we were
warming it up.
Typical humans.
This also means the act of installing the
instruments muddled the results of the heat
flow experiments.
But knowing where we went wrong will help
us design future missions.
Maybe we’ll keep this in mind when we’re
kicking up Martian dust one day in the far
future.
Thanks for watching, be sure to subscribe.
If you could move to the moon, would you?
You’d probably have to live in a cave…
Lunar Real Estate Agent, Trace explains this
crazy plan here.
One last thing: We could take pictures of
the astronauts tracks today because there’s
no wind or water on the moon to erode them.
Ok I’m out but I’ll see you next time
on Seeker.